When I see you growling, it
reminds me of last Christmas.
Excuse me, chicken please.
I'm the second person to say that sincere and kind person, and that person also encouraged me a lot.
But he's much more determined than me, and I'm really happy that he talks to suit me.Why am I
talking about this?
When I talk to Mr. Sakurai, I think of her.Do you
and I
look that much alike?
Yes, we
communicate only on the Internet, but the kindness in the choice of words
is similar to when Mr. Sakurai encouraged Yuki in the past.  It makes me feel good.
Next time I log in with Sakurai, I want to help her as a main character. She's a
so-called new hot pot
.  It's impossible to get along with each other. Absolutely
[music]
That's right, right?
It's not
because I'm Lily.